tell everyone because see i know the
process it took to get in this this is
marilyn monroe's dress
and it's 60 years old i tried it on it
didn't fit me and so i looked at them
and i said give me like three weeks and
i i had to lose 16 pounds
down today to
be able to fit this yep 16 pounds in
three weeks kim kardashian pulling off
that feet just in time to have this
maryland moment on the met steps
kardashian right here it was such a
challenge it was like a role right i was
determined yeah i was determined to win
it determination paid off a newly blonde
kim stunning in that iconic gown
originally worn by marilyn in 1962 as
she sang happy birthday to president
john f kennedy ripley's believe it or
not acquired the piece of history back
in 2016 and before the museum agreed to
loan kim the dress they invited her to
try on a replica for size i'm just so
grateful that even for the opportunity
oh my god you got it
[Music]
yeah that one fit perfectly but get this
after receiving the original naturally
delivered by private plane kim says
there was a little issue i had this idea
to to put it on and try it on and then
they came with like armed guards and
gloves and
i tried it on and it didn't fit me and
that's when she made it her mission to
fit into the dress
and so i looked at them and i said give
me like three weeks and i had to lose 16
pounds
down today to to be able to fit this but
i it was such a challenge it was like a
roll right i was determined yeah i was
determined to win it kim shared her
routine in detail with vogue telling the
mag i would wear a sauna suit twice a
day run on the treadmill completely cut
out all sugar and all carbs and just eat
the cleanest veggies and protein i
didn't starve myself but i was so strict
you just gotta roll with it in the end
all of her hard work was worth it but
after ascending those steps kim changed
out of the gown and into that replica
and don't worry kim totally treated
herself after the gala
okay guys so after the met i am starving
and my favorite donuts in the entire
world new york city are these mini
donuts
oh my god you guys i have them in the
room how cute is this
and pizza
it's safe to assume kim's boyfriend pete
davidson joined in on that junk
food-fueled after-party after the couple
made their met gala debut where they
couldn't help but show a little pda for
the cameras
together this way
you look amazing thank you you look
handsome you look hot thank you she
didn't let me wear my propeller hat but
it's fine and it seems kim and pete are
the real deal since being linked
romantically in october a source tells
e.t their relationship is still going
strong kim is head over heels for pete
they are in a great place in their
relationship and she is so happy her
family loves him too
what do you think of mr pete dave i
think he's great yeah
yeah making him very happy these days
he's great
[Music]
you